a los guardianes revolucionarios iraníes
han reconocido este ataque que se dio
esta mañana con al menos una docena de
misiles que fueron lanzados desde
territorio iraní rumbo a la capital del
kurdistán iraquí erbil al consulado
norteamericano un edificio que apenas
empieza a funcionar afuera de la ciudad
y que los iraníes dicen que también
tiene o alberga a base sionistas no es
la primera vez que irán acusa al
kurdistán iraquí de tener relaciones con
israel pero la primera vez que en un
ataque lo justifica esto llega cuatro
días después de un ataque en territorio
sirio por israel en el cual murieron
cuatro personas entre ellos dos
comandantes de los guardianes
revolucionarios lo interesante es que
esta no es la primera vez que israel
ataca a siria donde hay bases iraníes ni
tampoco es la primera vez que mueren
comandantes de la guardia revolucionaria
porque ahora esto llega en un momento en
el cual el acuerdo nuclear que se está
renegociando en vena ha quedado
estancado y esta vez no solamente por
esos puntos entre eeuu e irán que no se
han terminado de resolver sino porque
rusia ha pedido garantías para que pueda
beneficiarse de el acuerdo a pesar de
las sanciones económicas esto lo ha
estancado y también hay que recordar
siempre que son los rusos los que dan
permiso a israel de volar y atacar a las
bases iraníes en territorio sirio